Quand ma fille était en maternelle, chaque matin,
elle construisait un château sophistiqué avec des rubans et des blocs.
Chaque matin, le même petit garçon s'amusait à le démolir.
Ses parents étaient présents mais ne sont jamais intervenus préventivement.
Ils se contentaient d'affirmer des platitudes après coup :
« On ne changera pas les garçons. »
« La tentation est trop forte pour résister. »
J'ai agi comme de nombreuses filles et femmes ont appris.
J'ai cultivé la paix de manière préventive et j'ai demandé à ma fille de m'imiter.
Elle a traduit cela avec ses propres mots.
Elle a tenté de l'empêcher gentiment de démolir son château.
Elle a changé l'endroit de son château mais tout cela fut vain.
De fait, avec les autres adultes, nous avions érigé un droit masculin.
Il pouvait agir sans discernement et contrôler l'environnement
et elle devait taire ses émotions
et organiser son travail autour de ses besoins à lui.
Nous avons manqué à nos responsabilités vis-à-vis des deux enfants
en refusant à ma fille sa colère et la solution qu'elle méritait.
Ceci est une miniature d'un problème bien plus fondamental.
Car culturellement, dans le monde,
nous privilégions la performance masculine
et le pouvoir et le privilège qui l'accompagnent
aux dépens des droits, des besoins et de l'opinion des enfants et des femmes.
Vous ne serez donc pas du tout surpris d'apprendre
que les femmes déclarent être plus longuement en colère et plus intensivement
que les hommes.
Une des raisons émane du fait que la société nous apprend à ruminer,
à garder nos pensées pour nous et à les ressasser.
Toutefois, nous devons aussi trouver les mots que la société peut entendre
pour exprimer l'intensité des émotions que nous éprouvons
et faire prendre conscience aux gens la précarité que cela nous inflige.
Nous procédons de diverses manières.
Les hommes seraient stupéfaits d'apprendre
le nombre de fois que les femmes sont envahies par une rage froide
quand nous pleurons.
(Rires)
Nous minimisons nos propos.
« C'est frustrant, mais tout va bien. »
(Rires)
Nous nous réifions et perdons la capacité de reconnaître
les changements physiologiques qui accompagnent notre colère.
Souvent, cela nous rend malades.
On reconnaît depuis peu que la colère provoque un spectre de pathologies
souvent taxées de « pathologies typiquement féminines ».
Un taux plus élevé de douleurs chroniques, des troubles auto-immunes et alimentaires,
la détresse mentale, l'anxiété, l'automutilation ou la dépression.
La colère influence notre système immunitaire et cardio-vasculaire.
Des études mettent en évidence son influence sur le taux de mortalité,
particulièrement sur les femmes noires qui souffrent d'un cancer.
Je suis écœurée et fatiguée de voir des femmes écœurées et fatiguées.
Notre colère entraîne un grand embarras
et génère du conflit car notre rôle de femme est d'apporter du confort.
Mais certaines colères sont acceptables.
Nous pouvons être en colère
si nous restons dans notre rôle et renforçons le statu quo.
En tant que mères ou professeurs,
nous pouvons être fâchées, mais pas sur le coût ostentatoire de l'éducation.
Nous pouvons être en colère contre nos mères.
En tant qu'ado, contre les règles patriarcales et les règlements.
Nous n'accusons pas le système, mais elles.
Nous pouvons être fâchées avec d'autres femmes
car qui n'aime pas un bon petit crêpage de chignons ?
Nous pouvons être fâchées avec des hommes hiérarchiquement inférieurs à nous
et qui encouragent le racisme ou la xénophobie.
Cette colère-là nous confère un pouvoir énorme
car ces sentiments sont du ressort de notre autorité.
Or les gens ne se sentent pas à l'aise avec notre colère.
Nous devrions conduire les gens à se sentir plus à l’aise
avec leur sentiment de gêne
quand les femmes disent non en n'éprouvant aucun remords.
Nous pouvons voir les émotions en termes de compétences, et non plus de genres.
Les personnes capables de gérer leur colère et de lui donner du sens
sont plus créatives, plus optimistes,
créent plus d'espaces d'intimité,
résolvent mieux les problèmes
et ont un meilleur impact politique.
Je suis une femme, qui parle des femmes et de ce qu'elles éprouvent.
Par conséquent, peu d'hommes de pouvoir
vont me prendre au sérieux sur le plan politique.
Nous envisageons la politique et la colère à l'aune du mépris et de la fureur
qui nourrissent la montée du macho-fascisme dans le monde.
Pourtant, s'il s'agit d'un poison, c'est aussi un antidote.
Notre colère est fondée sur l'espoir et nous en sommes témoins au quotidien
dans la résistance furieuse des femmes et des personnes marginalisées.
C'est lié à la compassion, l'empathie et l'amour
et nous devrions reconnaître cette colère là aussi.
Les sociétés qui ne respectent pas la colère des femmes, en fait,
ne respectent pas les femmes.
Le véritable danger de notre colère
n'est pas qu'elle brise des liens ou des assiettes
mais qu'elle dévoile le sérieux de notre détermination
et notre attente que les autres nous prennent aussi au sérieux.
Quand cela arrivera, il y a de fortes chances
que les femmes pourront sourire quand elles le souhaitent.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
(Applaudissements) (Encouragements)